Selamlar bakalım 9. sınıf tayfam.
Nasılsınız? İyi misiniz? Keyifler nasıl
diyelim güzel arkadaşlarım. Evet
ilerlemeye devam ediyoruz. Üslü
sayılarda ilk dersimizi bitirmiştik.
Aslında ilk adımı attıktan sonra işin
geleceğini sen de biliyorsun. Şimdi üslü
sayılarda derinliğe ineceğiz. Ne
yapıyoruz? 9. sınıf kondisyon
yayınlarından kim serisindeki modülümüzü
aldın eline? Hala edinmediysen açıklama
kısmına ve videonun yorumlar kısmına
sabitledim linki. Hemen sen de modülü
eline alıyorsun. Sayfa kaçı açıyoruz?
İkinci ders için. 2. Şöyle gösteriyorum.
6. sayfadan başlıyoruz. 6 ve 7. sayfayı
birlikte işleyeceğiz. Önemli
başlıklarımız var. Üslü sayılarda
toplama çıkarmayı öğreneceğiz. Beraber
onu halledeceğiz. Ardından %100 olarak
sınav sorusunun geleceği noktalardan
birini söyleyeyim sana. Bilimsel
gösterim önemli bir tanım var. Bu
tanımla ilgili güzel sorular çözeceğiz.
Sonrasında dersimizi bitireceğiz. Hemen
bir sonraki 3üncü derse geçeceksin. Üslü
sayılarda. Üslü sayılarda en
derinlemesine, en zor örnekleri
çözdüğümüz ders üslü sayılardaki 3ün
ders olacak. Oraya geçince de yine
ilerliyor olacağız. Şimdi kitabımızı
açtık mı? Modülümüzü açtık mı? Hazırsak
ne diyoruz? İkinci dersiyle üslü sayılar
için gönder gelsin be hocam dedik. Evet.
Ne dedim? Üslü sayılarda toplama çıkarma
kısmındayım. Gerçekten çok kolay burası.
Şimdi sen neyle neyi toplayabilirsin onu
düşünelim. Öncelikle gittim bir manava
ne alaka diyeceksin. Manavda elmalar
var, armutlar var. Elmaları kendi içinde
toplayabilirsin. Armutları kendi içinde
toplarsın. Niye? İşte adamın elinde 50
tane elma vardı, 25 tane armut vardı
dersin. Öyle değil mi? Bizim üslü
sayılardaki mantık da aslında tamamen
buna dayanıyor. Şimdi ben üslü sayılarda
toplama çıkarma yapacağım ya. Öyle
kafama göre durduk yere o toplama
çıkarmayı yapamıyorsun. Üstlü ifadelerde
toplama çıkarma yapabilmem için ne lazım
sana? Hem tabanlar hem de üstler aynı
olmalı. Çünkü şöyle bir ifade oluşacak.
Örneğin 2 üzeri 3 var burada. Yan
tarafta da 2 üzeri 3 var. Önünde 5
çarpanı var. Atıyorum bunun önünde 3
çarpanı var. Abi tabanlar ve üstler
aynıysa bunları artık birer elma gibi
düşünebilirsin. Düşünsene burada bir
elma var. Burada bir elma var. 3 tane
elma buradan. 5 tane elma buradan. Kaç
tane elma yaptı? 8iz tane elma yaptı.
Aslında kolay bir mantı var. Yine
aslında ortaokuldaki bilgilerimizi
tekrar ettiğimiz eee konulardan biri
burası. Ama yeri geldiğinde önemli
noktalar geldiğinde ben zaten hepsini
sana ayrıntılı şekilde açıklıyor
olacağım. Buralar kolay olacak. O yüzden
yukarıda belirtilen özelliği sağlayan
üstlü ifadelerin katsayıları arasında
toplama çıkarma işlemini yaparsın. Ha
diğer hallerde yapılamaz mı hocam?
Yapılabilir ama özel bazı dokunuşlar
lazım. O dokunuşların da nasıl
yapıldığını göstereceğim. Peki o dokunuş
ne zaman lazım oluyor hocam? Tabanları
aynı fakat üstleri farklı haldeyse.
Örneğin 2 üzeri 2 var. 2 üzeri 3 var. Şu
haliyle bu işlemleri toplayabilir misin?
Hayır. Ya sayıları düzenlersin, biri
4'ler, biri 8izleri toplarım hocam
dersin. Ya da arkadaş 2 üzeri 3 aslında
yan yana 3 tane 2'nin çarpımı mıdır?
Evet. 2 üzeri 2'ye dokunmadım. O zaten
küçük olan. Büyük olanı dedim ki şu bir
tane ikisini ayıralım. Geriye ne kalır?
2in karesi kalır. Doğru mudur? Artık
tabanlar da üstler de birbirinin aynısı
oldu mu? Oldu. Şimdi bu işlemleri ne
yapabilirim dersin. Ha, şimdi toplarım.
Dikkat et. Burada bir elma var. Burada
kaç tane elma var? İki tane elma var ya.
İnanılmaz basitleştiriyor aslında böyle
düşündüğünde. Tane tane topluyormuşun
gibi oluyor. Hocam 3 tane elma oldu. E
biz kime elma demiştik? 2 üssü 2. O
zaman 3 x 2 üssü 2. Tabii ki bu işin
basitleştirilmiş kısmı. Matematik kısmı
nasıl olacak? Ben sana diyeceğim ki
arkadaş a x üssü + b x üssü - c x üssü
şeklinde sana verdiğim bir işlem var. Bu
işlemi lütfen yapar mısın? Nasıl
yapacaksın? Hepsine bakıyorsun tek.
Hocam bunların hepsinde üslü ifade
olarak x üssüne tabanları da üstleri de
birbirinin aynısı mı? Aynısı. İşte o
zaman bu işlemleri artık özünde yaptığın
işlem hani ben az önce elma elma dedim
ama özünde yaptığın işlem matematiksel
olarak x üssü n parantezine almak. Bak
bunları burada x üssü n parantezine
alınca burada kim kaldı? A kaldı. Burada
kim kaldı? Bak sadece bde mi? + b kaldı.
İşlemi ile birlikte almanda fayda var.
Burada ne kaldı? Bak sadece C demiyorum
hocam. Orada -C kaldı. Eksisi ile
birlikte alıyorsun. Önünde de çarpı var.
A + B - C x üssü. Bizim üslü sayılarda
toplama çıkar mı? Bu haliyle bu şekilde
yapılacak. Şimdi tane tane başlayalım
seninle. Hocam ilk toplamayı yapar mıyız
beraber? 3 x 2 üzeri 4 + 2 üzeri 4
işleminde aslında ben burayı 2 üsü 4
parantezine aldığımda şu şekilde 2 üstü
hocam.
>> Efendim ders anlatıyordum yalnız
videodayım. Bir sorum olacak m
>> sor.
>> Bir matematik konular.
>> Dur gel bari kadraja gir azıcık
görsünler. En azından kamerayı
görsünler. Bir yandan da video çekiyor.
Bak reşi söyle rejim.
>> Bir matematik konusunu çıkarmak
isteseniz böyle tamamen müfredattan
çıkaracaksınız.
>> Niye çıkarıyoruz?
>> Çıkarıyoruz. Öyle bir şey geldi size.
>> Ne geldi? Yetki mi verdiler? Aa bana
yetkiyi verdiler. Verdin yetkiyi
göreceksin yetkiyi. Şimdi söyle ne
istiyorsun? Ne istiyorsun? Söyle.
>> Yetki veriyoruz size. Matematikten bir
konuyu tamamen çıkaracağız. Bütün lise
müfredatı içerisinde mi 9. sınıf
anlatıyordum yoksa şu anda
>> yok bütün lise müfredatı
>> valla ben neyi atardım biliyor musun?
Yani permütasyon, kombinasyon, olasılık
alayını bir toptan atardım. Çünkü öyle
bir konu ki ne kadar soru çözersen çöz
abi o konuda hani mükemmelim diyemezsin.
Öyle bir ters köşe soru sorarlar ki
patlatırlar adamı. Ya Allah'tan ÖSYM son
dönem doğrudan kolay sorular soruyor.
Eskiden zorluyordu bazen ama PKO'yu
gönderdim gitti ya. Seni de gönderiyorum
yalnız. Tamam. Seni de tamam gönder
gitsin. PKO diyoruz.
>> Tamam. Aynen öyle. Hadi seni de
gönderelim de biz kaldığımız yerden
dersimize devam edelim. Şimdi bak
toplama yapıyorduk biz. Nereden nereye
geldi mevzu? Bir dakika. Ne diyordum
hocam? 2 üssü 4 dedik değil mi burada? 2
üsü 4 parantezine aldın mı? Aldım.
Burada kim kaldı? Tek başına 3 kaldı.
Artı burada ne kaldı tek başına? Tamam
git kare.
Burada ne kaldı? Gitmiyor. Gitmiyor
hala. Gitmiyor da. Şurada bak tek başına
+1 kaldı. Şurada +1'i de ekliyorum.
Hocam dur dağıldık diyorsun. Yok be da
daha almadık. Bak hocam burada ne var
artık? 3 1 daha 4 var. 4 x 2 üssü 4.
Daha sonraki derste üslü sayılarda
çarpmayı da anlatınca aslında bu işlemin
devam ettiğini de göstereceğim. Tamam.
Şimdi gel yine 3 üzeri x 3 üzeri x 3
üzeri x. Buradaki 3 üzeri x'ler ortak
olduğuna göre ben 3 üsü x parantezine
alamaz mıyım? Şimdi ben böyle alınca
paranteze hep sola yazarım. Herkes de
zannediyor ki öyle yazılmak zorunda
abim. Öyle falan yazılmak zorunda değil.
Ben alışkanlık yeri öyle yapıyorum.
Şimdi bak burada ne kaldı? 7 kaldı.
sağına yazıyor. -2
+ Bak bunu alınca buradan aslında 1
çarpanı kalır. + 1'i kalır. 7'den 2
çıktı ne kaldı? 5. 1 ekledin ne yaptı?
6. 6 x 3 üssü x. Dediğim gibi çarpmayı
anlatınca üslü sayılarda burada daha
devam eden bir işlem daha var. Onu da
göstermiş olacağım. Peki hocam bu işlem
ondalık sayılarda da yapılabiliyor mu?
Aslında bizim asıl derdimiz zaten biraz
da ondalıklarla uğraşmak. Çünkü bir
sonraki başlığımızda bilimsel gösterim
var. Dediğim gibi sınav sorusu. Kesin
oradan bekliyorum. Orayla ilgili
işlemleri yapabilmek için o ondalıklara
da hakim olmak gerekiyor. 5 üssü 2
parantezine aldığında artık sayın 2,7 +
1,3'e dönüştü mü? Toplayamayan için 1,7
1,3 toplarken 7 3 10 elde var 1 virgülü
aynen koydum 2 1 daha 3 1 de elde 4
aslında 4,0 diye bir sayı yok 4 diye bir
sayı var o halde ben 4 x 5'in karesi
şeklinde bu ifadeyi yazabilirim tamam
mıyız? Devam ettim hocam. 2 üssü 5 2 üsü
5 2 üssü 5 çok bariz bir şekilde 2 üssü
5 parantezine aldım. Bak bu sefer de
soluna yazalım. Şurada ne var? 13 + 12 -
7 x 2 üssü -5
e buradaki işlemi şöyle bir bitirelim
istersen. 3 oradan 2 oradan burada 5
kaldı. 13 5 daha cevap ne yaptı? 18
yaptı. 18 x 2 üzeri -5 benim elde
ettiğim son halidir. Yola devam. 3 üssü
3, 3 üssü 2, 3 üssü 2. Dur, top burada
patladı işte hocam. Hayırdır? Ne oldu? 3
üsü 3 var. O zaman biz sadece bu iki
işlemi yapalım. Bu kenarda mı kalsın?
Hayır. Tabanları aynı mı? Aynı.
Üstlerinden ikisi aynı, biri farklı. Ama
o kadar yakın değerler ki ben bunu
toparlarım arkadaş. O yüzden bak bunu
burada aşağıda çözelim beraber. Şimdi 12
dediğim sayıyı bıraktım. 3 üssü 3
dediğin sayı 3 x 3 x 3 değil midir?
Şimdilik öyle kalsın. Hiç acele etme. 7
x 3ün kares + 2 x 3ün karesi. Bu
şekildeydi zaten sorumuz. Şimdi diyorum
ki hocam bak burada üstlü sayının tanımı
gereği aslında bu ifade artık 3'ün
karesi şeklinde ifade edilebilir mi?
İfade edilebilir. Artık zaten bütün
buradaki ifadeler 3'ün karesi olduğu
için paranteze alınırımı sonrasında
alınır. Demek ki istediğime ulaştım.
İsteyince düzenlenebiliyormuş. E bu
tarafta oluşan sayı ne? 12 ile 3'ün
çarpımı. 12 ile 3'ü çarptın cevap ne?
36. Yanında ne var? 3ün karesi -7 x 3ün
karesi o 3'e ne oldu? Tövbe ya rabbim
çarpıldı. 3ün karesi
2 x 3ün karesi ekmeğe basmış. Tövbeim o
3. O yamuldu gitti. Şimdi yola devam. -7
+ 2 daha ne yapar? -5 tane 3 üzeri ya da
hiç uzatmayayım mı? Niye öyle yapıyorsun
ki hocam? 3 üzeri 2 parantezine
aldığında 36 - 7 + 2 gelmez mi? Burası
da 3ün karesi değil mi? Şurası ne yaptı?
-5 yaptı. 36'dan 5 çıktı. Geriye ne
kaldı? 31 kaldı. 31 x 3ün karesi benim
aradığım bu sorunun cevabı olmuş oldu.
Hatta hadi gel bunu da hiç
sıkıştırmayalım yukarıya. Onu da şuraya
aşağıya çözelim beraber. Hepsine
bakıyorsun önce üstlü sayılarda. Lütfen
buraya atlama. Acele de etme. Hemen
toplamaya çıkarmaya çalışma. Tabanlar
aynı, üstler aynı değilse işlemi
yapamıyordun. Çünkü dedim ki hocam bak
10 üzeri -7 hepsinde ortak olan bir
çarpan. 0,26 var burada. 0,26
+ 0,74
- 0,1 değil mi? 0,26
0,74
önce bunları bir toplayalım istersen. 6
4 daha 10 elimde var. 1 7 2 daha ne
yaptı? 8 1 pardon 7 2 daha ne yaptı? 9 1
daha ne yaptı? 10 şurası 0 şurası 1. A
tam 1 oluyor orası. Bundan da neyi
çıkarıyorsun? 0,1'i çıkarıyorsun. E
geriye zaten 0,9 kalmayacak mıdır? O
halde buradaki ifade 0,9 x 10 üzeri -7
olarak ne yapılır? Elde edilir. Şimdi
bak toplama çıkarma üstüne gerçekten
yoğunlaşalım biraz daha. Şuradaki
örnekleri de yapalım. Örnek 2'deki iyice
pekiştirelim buradaki soruları. Aşağıda
verilen ifadeleri ortak çarpan
parantezine uygun olarak yerlerini
doldurunuz diyor. Hadi gel dolduralım.
Hepsinde ortak eleman var mı? Var. O
halde ne diyorsun? 3 üssü 5 parantezine
aldım. Buradan 2 geldi hocam. Artı
buradan ne geldi? 1 geldi. Toplamı ne
yaptı? 3. 3 x 3 üssü 5. Dedim ya bir
sonraki derste çarpmayı da anlatınca
aslında bunun 3 üssü 6'ya eşit olduğunu
söyleyeceğim. Nasıl söyleyeceğim biliyor
musun? Bak tabanlar aynı. Tabanlar aynı
iken arada çarpma işlemim varsa üstler
toplanır. Bu ifade 3 üssü 6'ya eşittir.
Şimdi bilmesem bile aslında 3 x 3 üssü
5'in anlamı da e 5 tane 3'ün yan yana
çarpımı demektir. E toplamda burada kaç
tane 3 oldu? 6 tane oldu. Bir nevi
ispatıyla da göstermiş oldum. Gerçi
aramızda illaki bilen arkadaşlar vardır
ama ben herkes öğrensin diye
anlatıyorum. Tamam mı? 5in karesi 5in
karesi var mı? Var hocam. Ne parantezine
alınacak? 5in karesi parantezine
alınacak. Önünde ne var burada? -6.
Yanında ne var burada? + 8. 8'den 6
çıktı. Ne kaldı? 2. 2 çarpı neyi elde
ettim? 5in karesini elde ettim. Var mı
bir sıkıntı? Yok. Güzel. O zaman hadi
bakalım yola devam. Hocam ortak
elemanları söyle. 7 üzeri 3. 7 üzeri 3.
O halde yine ben ne parantezine aldım? 7
üzeri 3. Yanda ne kaldı? 2,8 -1,2.
Herhalde bunu kafadan çıkarız ya. 8'den
2 çıktı 6 kaldı. 2'den 1 çıktı 1 kaldı.
1,6 tabii o sarı sayı çarpı 7 üssü 3 de
yanında cabası hocam. A üssü b a üssü b
lütfen her seferinde teyit et. Bak ben
her şeyi bilmeme rağmen ne yapıyorum?
Yine de teyit ediyorum. Aman diyeyim
yanlış bir şey olmasın. İster böyle yaz
bu sayıyı istersen x + y x a üssü b
şeklinde yaz. Tabii ki ikisi de aynı
anlama geliyor. Bak mesela bu çok güzel.
Hocam burada ne var ki öyle? Güzel
dedin. X üssü N burada var mı? Burada da
x üssü N var mı? Var. Amaç neydi? X üssü
N parantezine almak. Alacağım ama. E
hocam bu parantez içinde hiç sıkıntı
değil. Artık onu böyle açık şekilde
yazabilirsin. Yandan ne geliyor? - N
geliyor. - N'nini yaz. X üssü N oldu mu?
Oldu. E bu N'ler birbirini götürdüm. 1 +
1 ek önde sadece m çarpanı kaldı. Yanda
da x üssü n çarpanı kaldı. Güzel. Şimdi
yine geldim buna. a x üssü m x üssü m
ifadesi ortaksa eğer x üssü m
parantezine alacağım. Kalan elemanları
yazıyorum. a - 1 + a x üssü m. Dikkat et
harfler seni korkutmasın. İlla sayı
gelmeli hocam üst sayılarla. Dur ya
harflerle de gelebilir artık. Lise
öğrencisiyiz biz. Hatta öyle anlar
gelecek ki sayı göremeyeceğiz ha. Sırf
harflerle sorular çözeceğiz. Hocam
burası ne oldu? Artık 2a - 1 x x üssü m
ifadesine dönüştü. Bence iyice yerleşti.
Şurada son iki örneğimizi de yapalım
artık. Üslü ifadelerde toplama çıkarma
kısmını geçelim. Artık yeter. Bilimsel
gösterim lazım bize. Dediğim gibi asıl
can alıcı nokta orası. Oradan sınav
sorusu bekliyorum. %100. Ama bunu da
bilmeden oraya geçiş yapamıyoruz. Şimdi
uzunca bir işlem var burada ama dikkat
et bu sefer arada eşitlik var. Bunun
anlamı nedir hocam? Arada eşitlik
olduğuna göre demek ki sol taraftaki
işlemin sonucu bu gelmek zorunda. Doğru
mu? Tamam. O zaman x değerine
odaklanıyorum. Nasıl çözebilirim diye.
Sol taraftaki işlemlere bakıyorum. Hepsi
üslü ifade ve bütün o üslü ifadelerin
hepsinin tabanı da üssü de birbirinin
aynısı. Hocam arada da toplama çıkarma
var. O halde biz ne parantezine alırız?
10 üzeri hatta şu sola doğru yazayım
biraz. 10 üzeri -7 parantezine alırız.
Açtım. Parantez 2 + şurada ne var? 1,4
var. Artı burada ne var? X var.
Kapattım. Parantez arada çarpma. Karşı
tarafta ne var? 1,4 x 10 üssü -7. Bir
tur daha düzenleyeceğim. Şimdi bu iki
ifadeyi topladığımda 2 + 1,4 ne yaptı
hocam? 3,4 yaptı. Yanında ne var? + x'i
var. Süper. Çarpı bu tarafta 10 üzeri -7
var. Karşıda da 1,4 x 10 üssü -7 var.
Artık tek yapmam gereken şey arkadaş sol
tarafta ve sol taraftaki şu iki ifade
birbirine eşit mi? Aslında birbirini
götürüyorlar. Sadeleşiyorlar çarpım
durumunda olduğu için. Ya da hiç
sadeleşiyorlar gibi düşünme. Zaten onlar
birbirine eşit. Eşitliğin korunabilmesi
için buradaki iki ifadenin de eşit
olması lazım. Yani 3,4'ü x ile
topladığında cevap 1,4 çıkmadı. X'i
yalnız bıraktığında 1,4'ten aslında o
nasıl bir 3'tür? 3,4'ü çıkartmayacak
mıyım? 0 4'ten 04. Yani şuradaki 4
ondalık kısmı çıktığında 0 kalır. 1'den
3 çıktığında cevap ne olur? -2. Tabii ki
düzenlemem gerektiğinde x'in cevabı ne
olacaktır? -2 olacaktır. Vurdum cevabı
-2'ye. Geçtim sıradaki soruya. Yine aynı
mantık var ama buradaki olaya lütfen
dikkat et. Eşitliğin sağ tarafında kim
var? 10un karesi var. Eşitliğin sol
tarafında kim var? 10un karesi var. Ama
bir tane de hocam burada 10 üzeri 3 var.
O zaman bu şu an bu işlemi yapamazsın.
Niye? Toplama yapacaksın, çıkarma
yapacaksın. Üstlerin birbirine,
tabanların birbirine aynı eşit olması
gerekiyordu. O zaman benim 10 üzeri üsü
3'ü düzenlemem lazım. Bak 10 üzeri 3
dediğin sayı 10 x 10 x 10 mudur? Üslü
sayının tanımından yapıyorum. Ne
demiştim? Zekayla değil, matematik
tanımla yapılır. Bunu kulağına küpe et.
Kim ne derse desin. Hocam ben çok zeki
değilim. Matematik yapabilirsin.
Çok net. Yeter ki tanımları öğren. Ne
var hocam burada? 10un karesi. Bak üslü
sayının tanımını kullanıyorum. Bir şey
kullanmıyorum. Burada yanında ne var? 10
var. 10 x 10un karesi. Var mı bir
sıkıntı? Buraya kadar bilmediğimiz,
öğrenmediğimiz, yeni gördüğümüz hiçbir
şey yok. O zaman gel. Şuradan ne
geliyor? 1,2 geliyor. Çarpı buradan ne
geliyor artık? 10 x 10un karesi geldi.
-0,6
x 10un kares = x x 10un kares. Şimdi
işlemleri yaparım ama gönül ister. Şunu
bir düzenle kardeşim. Böyle bırakma.
1,2'yi 10'la çarpmak demek. Hani bak
bunun 0ını bir ileri götürmek demek.
Hani bilmeyen için. Şimdi ortaokulda ne
kadar bilgim var bilmiyorum ama ben sana
hepsini anlatayım. 1,2 rasyonel olarak
yazılabilir.
Virgülün sağında bir sayı olduğu için
10'a böldüm demektir o. 12'yi 10'a
böldüğünde 1,2 elde edersin. E sen bu
sayıyı bir de 10'la çarpıyorsun.
Cırtana, cırt sana bunlar gitti. Aslında
bu ifade kaça eşittir? 12 eşit. Demek ki
ben bu ifadenin yerine 12 x 10un kares
-0,6 x 10un kares x ya e= x x 10un
karesi şeklinde yazmam lazım. Şu iki
işlemi bir yapalım hocam. Bak burada
10un karesi var. 10un karesi var. 10un
karesi parantezine aldım. 12'den 0,6'yı
çıkaracağım. Çıkartalım istersen. Bak
çıkartıyorum şu şekilde. Biliyorum
ondalık sayılarda bazen
zorlanılabiliyor. Buraya bir 10'luk
attın. 10'dan 6 çıktı. Ne kaldı? 4
kaldı. Şurada birlik kaldı. Hop, burada
da 1 kaldı. Cevabım ne oldu? 11,4 x 10
üsü 2. Karşıda ne var? X x 10 üsü 2. Ne
demiştik? Bunlar zaten bu eşitliği
sağlayan arkadaşlar. Bu eşitliğin devam
edebilmesi için he x'in 11,4'e
eşit olması lazımdır dedik. İlk
sayfamızı bitirdik. Her sayfada benimle
birlikte bu tiki atıyorsun. Çünkü konuyu
da anladım, soruyu da anladım. Zerre
kafamda soru işareti kalmadı diyorsun.
Ha ola kaldı arkadaş. O zaman ne
diyorsun? Hangi soruda takıldım? Mesela
ben buraya sazan koydum ama şimdi sazan
diyorum ben size sorularda bazen. Mesela
4. soruda takıldın abi. Dön bak yazacak
şekilde oraya bir ikon koyarsın. Bir
sticker yapıştırırsın. Sonrasında ne
yaparsın? Modülünü eline aldığında
sınava hazırlanırken tekrar edeceğin
zaman a bir dakika bu soruya ben özel
bir işaret koymuşum. Demek ki bir daha
çözmem gerek dersin. Bunlar bizim için
çok önemli. Anlaştık mı? Şimdi gel
benimle gel gel gel.
Şimdi ne dedi Mehmet hoca? Dedi ki
sınavda bilimsel gösterimden soru
gelecek. Lütfen elinden kalemi, kitabı
lütfen bir bırak. Bir bırak. Sadece
gözlerinle tamamen kulaklarınla,
benliğinle, her şeyinle bana odaklan.
Bende misin? Şimdi gel. Hocam bilimsel
gösterim demek ne demek biliyor musun?
Çok büyük, çok küçük sayıların
gösteriminde kullanılır. Ama matematiğin
her yerinde olduğu gibi burada da
bilimsel gösterimi anlamak istiyorsan,
sorularını doğru yapmak istiyorsan
bilmen gereken tek bir şey söyleyeceğim
sana. Tanım. Şaka maka diye. Hocam siz
kafayı yemişsiniz tanımla. Abi ben
yemedim. Matematik kafayı zaten bozmuş
tanımla. Ama tanım bilinci olacak. Şimdi
bilimsel gösterimde A 0'dan farklı bir
gerçel sayı. N de bir tam sayı olmak
üzere A denen sayının bak bulunduğu
aralığa dikkat et. 1 ile 10 aralığında
olacak. 1'e eşit olabilir, 10'a eşit
olamaz. Tabii mutlak değerce. Bunun
anlamı şu. Burası negatif de olabilir.
Negatif de olsa mutlak değerini
aldığında cevap ya 1'e eşit olacak ya da
10dan küçük olacak. O zaman şöyle
söyleyebilir miyim? Bir basamaklı
pozitif sayı olacak abi. Ya da mutlak
değeri bir basamaklı pozitif sayı
olacak. Ya da bir basamaklı pozitifte
negatifte sayı olacak. Doğru mudur? İki
basamaklı olmuyor. Bir de 0dan hariç
olacak. 0dan farklı olduğunu özellikle
söylemiştik. Eğer bu durumlarda ben
kalkıp şu şekilde o sayıyı
yazabiliyorsam a x 10 üstüne yani 10un
kuvveti şeklinde gösterebiliyorsam biz
bu tarz gösterime bilimsel gösterim
adını vereceğiz. Ama tekrar söylüyorum
buranın en önemli noktası a'yı aldığın o
değer aralığında tutturmanı lazım. Bunu
yazarsan işin çok kolaylaşır. Bence hiç
uzatmayalım. Dediğim gibi işte bak
atomlarda, elektronlarda küçük kütleli
maddelerin gösteriminde ya da aşırı
büyük kütleli ya da aşırı uzaklıkların
gösteriminde bilimsel gösterim
kullanılır. İşte atıyorum dünyanın
Mars'a uzaklığı, Güneşe uzaklığı gibi
tabirlerde yukarıda verilen tablodaki
sayıların bilimsel gösterimlerini
yazınız. Yazacağım ama burada şu notu
ben öncesinde vermek istiyorum sana.
Sebebine gelince bu notu bilirsen üslü
sayılardaki o virgül kaydırma olayını
çözdün demektir. Virgül kaydırma olayını
çözersen dünyanın en kolay sorusu olacak
bilimsel gösterim. Bir de tanımını
biliyorsan tabii. Şimdi bak lütfen beni
dikkatle dinle. Artık elinde kalem
olabilir bu arada. Benimle birlikte not
alıyorsun. Çok küçük, çok büyük sayıları
virgül kaydırarak gösterebiliriz. Mesela
167,96
x 10 üzeri 4 var. Hedefimiz şu olsun.
Seninle birlikte iyice yaklaştırıyorum.
Gör. Ben virgülü buradan alıp buraya
koymak istiyorum. Anlaştık mı? Bunu
normal şartlarda nasıl yaparsın? Bir
sayıyı 10'la çarparak virgülü sağa doğru
kaydırabilirsin. Ama bir şey
söyleyeceğim. Sen şimdi 167
9,6 yazdığında aslında bu sayıyı kaçla
çarpmış oluyorsun? 10'la çarpmış
oluyorsun. Buna eşit olacak mı? Olacak.
Virgül bir tane sağa kayacak. Hocam ya
hayatım güzel gülüm güzel söylüyor.
Hayatım gülüm falan. Ne oluyorsun hocam?
10'la çarpıyorsun da durduk yere bir
sayıyı 10'la çarpmak demek o sayının
aslında ne yapmak demektir? Eee,
ifadesini büyütmek demektir. Ama durduk
yere bir sayıyı büyütemezsin ki. Sayının
değişmemesi için o sayıyı 10'la
çarparken aynı zamanda kaça bölersin?
10'a bölersin. Şimdi ben 10'la çarptım.
Buradaki virgül ne oldu? Bir tane sağa
doğru gitti. Çarpı burada 10 üsü 4 var.
10 üssü 4 demek aslında 4 tane onluğun
yan yana çarpımı mı demektir? Evet.
Aşağıda bir onluk var bölüm durumunda.
Şunlar sadeleşti. Aslında burada 10 üssü
3 mü kaldı? Yanında ne kaldı? 10 üssü 3
kaldı. Şimdi çıkaracağımız sonucu
beraber görelim. Burası bu işin ispatı.
Bu işin gerçekten bilimsel anlamda
yapılışı. Matematiksel anlamda yapılışı.
Ben burada virgülü bir tane sağa doğru
kaydırdığımda
olan işlemi önce bana tarif eder misin?
Aşağı okuma. Kopaya çcek mi? Virgülü bir
tane sağa kaydırmak demek şuradaki 10un
kuvvetini bir tane azaltmak demektir.
Çünkü bunu sağa kaydırırken 10'la
çarparsın. Bunun üstünü bir azaltırsan
ona bölersin. Çarpıp bölersen 10'la
sayıda bir değişiklik olmaz. Benim de
istediğim buydu zaten. Peki hedef şu
olsun. Virgülü bir tane sola kaydırmak
istiyorum. Sola kaydırdığımda önce
sayının görünümünü yazalım. 16,796
oldu. Çarpı arkadaş sola kaydırmak demek
aslında bu sayıyı kaça bölmek demektir?
10'a. Bu sayıyı 10'a böldüğünde virgül
sola kayar. Ya sen bir sayıyı 10'a
bölüyorsun kafana göre de. O zaman
işlemin sonucu değişmemesi için ne
yaparsın? Tekrar 10'la çarparsın. E 10
üzeri 4'te kaç tane onluk vardı? 4 tane.
Tekrar bir 10'la çarpınca artık burada
kaç tane onluk oldu? 5 tane. Yani üslü
sayının tanımı gereği. Yanına artık ne
yazıyorsun? 10 üssü 5 yazıyorsun. Peki
yine varmak istediğimiz sonuç ne hocam?
Virgülü sola kaydırdığımda onun
kuvvetini bir arttırım. Virgülü sağa
kaydırdığımda eski yerini de şöyle
gösterelim. Bak eski yeri buradaydı.
Eski yeri buradaydı. Buradan buraya
kaydırdım. Buradan buraya kaydırdım.
Virgülü sağa kaydırdığımda üst bir
azalır. Virgülü sola kaydırdığımda üst
bir artar. Bu işin ezber kısmı. Ben sana
asla ezberle demem ama pratik olması
için bazen de matematikte ezberebilmen
de hatırlamda fayda var. Ama mantığını
öğrettiğimi düşünüyorum. İspatını yaptık
ki biz seninle her şeyin ispatını
yapacağız. Matematiği derinlemesine
öğrendiğinde bir kere öğrenip unutmamak
adına yapman gereken şey budur. Peki
aşağıda artık yazmışız. Eşitlikleri
incelendiğinde virgül basamağı sağa
kaydığında onun kuvveti 1 azalır.
Bir basamak sola kaydığında virgülümüz
kuvveti 1 artar. Bu kadar bu iş. Ama
ezberlememeye çalış bu işi. Tamam mı?
Şimdi gel. Bunun diyor bilimsel
gösterimini yapar mısınız? Bilimsel
gösterimin tanımı kafamızın kenarında
dursun. Bana önce bunu üstlü sayı
biçiminde yaz arkadaş. Şurada 15 sayısı
var mı? Var. Çarpı 1 2 3 4 5 6 tane 0
var mı? Var. Burası artık neye eşit? 15
x 10 üzeri 6'ya eşit. Ama sana bir
haberim var. Bunu üstü şekilde yazmış
olmam bilimsel gösterim olmaz. Bilimsel
gösterim senden ne istiyordu? Onun
önündeki buradaki katsayının
1'e eşit olabileceğini ya da bir
basamaklı. Ya abi en kolayı bu. bir
basamaklı olmasını istiyor. Bu kaç
basamaklı? İki basamaklı. Olmaz. Bir
basamaktan kastım da şu. Yani rasyonel
olabilir. Yani ondalıklı olabilir ama 1
ile 10 aralığında olacak. Bir basamaktan
kastım o yüzden yanlış anlama. Şimdi 15
sayısını ben aslında 10'a bölersem yani
şurada bir virgül var gözükmeyen. O
virgülü sola taşırsam bu sayı neye
dönüşür? 1,5'ğa dönüşür. Ama virgülü
sola taşırsam sayı küçülür. Küçülmemesi
için buradaki üssü ne yaparsın? 1
arttırırsın. Demek ki bunun bilimsel
gösterim 1,5 x 10 üsü 7. Neden 1,5
yapmaya çalıştın hocam abiciğim? Tanım
ne diyorsa o matematikte zekayla
yapılsaydı adam 15 x 10 üzeri belki 6'da
bırakırdı ama tanımla yapılıyor
matematik. O yüzden 1,5 x 10 üzeriydi.
Gel hemen hızlıca yapalım. 6 var mı
burada? Var. Çarpı 1 2 3 4 5 ne yaptı? 6
x 10 üsü 5 yaptı. Kabul müyüz efendim?
Kabul. Güzel. Şimdi ben sana bir şey
söyleyeceğim burada arkadaş. 6 x 10
üzeri 5'te tanıma uyuyor mu? 1 ile 10
arasında olacak. 1'e eşit olabilir. E
süper uyuyor. O zaman ne diye eşitti
koyuyorum? Bilimsel gösterdin zaten sen
bunu. Bitti hocam. 476 la. 476'yı
bilimsel gösterebilmem için benim
buradaki sayının bak virgül burada olsa
kurtarmaz. Virgül burada olsa heh o
zaman kurtulur. Normal şartlarda bu
sayının yanında gözükmeyen ne vardır? 10
üzeri 0 vardır. Biz ne dedik az önce
kuralı anlatırken? virgül iki basamak
sola kaydırmak demek yanındaki onun
kuvvetini 2 arttırmak demektir. O halde
bunun bilimsel gösterimi 4,76 x 10 üzeri
2'dir. Anlıyor musun ne demek
istediğimi? Bunlar çok kritik vakalar.
Şimdi hep sola kaydırdık virgülü
kaydırmak gerektiğinde. Şimdi sola
kaydırmayalım. Soru benden şunu istiyor.
Dikkat et. Bunun bilimsel gösterimini
istiyor. Sağa doğru kaydırmam lazım
virgülü. Yanında onun kuvveti var mı?
Yok. Sakın bana yok deme abi. Yok
diyemezsin. Matematikte var. 10 üzeri 0
nedir? 1dir. Aslında ben buraya dilersem
10un kuvvetini yazarım. Yazmadan
bilimsel gösterim olmuyor malumun.
Virgüle ne yapmam lazım hocam? 1 2 3 4
tane kaydıracağım. Sayı 6 olacak. E
virgülü 4 kaydırmak demek bunu 4 ile
çarpmak demektir. O halde üstünden kaç
çıkaracağım? 4 çıkaracağım. Virgül sağa
götürmek demek, sağa kaydırmak demek
onun kuvvetini birer birer azaltır. Ben
4 tane götürürsem 4 azaltırım. 0'dan 4
çıktı -4. 6 x 10 üzeri -4 eksili kısım
biraz zordur. O yüzden örneğim var. Bak
daha rahat ol. Bak şimdi yanında ne var?
10 üzeri 0 var. Müthiş. 1 2 3 tane
kaydırdım. Demek ki onun kuvvetini ne
yapacağım? 3 azaltacağım. 0 da -3 oldu.
Müthiş. Bilimsel gösterimin tanımına
uyuyor mu? Bak Mehmet hocayı koy bir
kenara. Tanıma uyuyor mu? Uyuyorsa
tamamdır. Doğru yoldasın. 1 2 3 4 5
Nerede duracağız? 6 3,12 yaptı. O zaman
işime geldi. 3,12 x normalde burada 10
üzeri 0 vardı. O zaman 6 virgül
kaydırdığıma göre sağa demek ki üstünden
onun kuvvetinin üstünden 6 çıkarmam
lazım. 3,12 x 10 üzeri -6 bizim
aradığımız cevaptır. Taşlar yerine
oturmaya başladı mı? Buralar çok iyi
anlaşılmalı. Çok iyi abim. Buradan %100
soru gelecek. Bak 2inci soru da değil.
Gelirse 3ün 4. soru gibi sorular
gelebilir. Onlara dikkat edeceğiz. Ama
önce tabii bunlar bizim işin iyice
pekiştirmemizi, öğrenmemizi sağlayacak.
Örnek. Bıdı bıdı sayısının bilimsel
gösterimi x 10 üzeri 7 olduğuna göre x +
y toplamı nedir? Bak aslında şunu
söylüyor. 0 bir dakika. 1 2 3 4 5 6. 1 2
3 4 5 6 dediğim sayı 7di değil mi? 1 2 3
4 5. Tamam. Bu sayı neye eşitmiş? X x 10
üssü y'ye eşitmiş. Aslında bunların
bilimsel gösterimi demek buna eşit.
Şimdi beraber düşünelim. Virgülü kaç
tane iktireceğim? 1 2 3 4 5 yetmez 6.
Yanında ne var? 10 üzeri 0 vardı. 6 tane
sağa kaydırırsam üstünden ne çıkartırım?
6 çıkartırım. Artık bu ifade x 10 üzeri
y şeklinde gösterildi mi? Gösterildi.
Demek ki buradaki ifadeler ne olacak?
Birbirlerine eşit olacaktır. X'in de
y'nin de neye eşit olduğunu buldum. x =
7'ymiş. y = -6'ymış. Soru benden x +
y'yi istiyordu. 7 -6 cevabım ne yaptı? +
1. Yalnız sadece tek başına 1 olsa da
sen yalnız değilsin. Biz beraberiz. Bu
işi beraber götüreceğiz. Lütfen. Şimdi
hep diyorum ya bunlar bizim aslında özel
ders konseptimiz. Özel derste olsa açtık
bu soruyu. Mesela sayfa kaçtayız? 7.
sayfadayız. 7. sayfada koydum önüne
abiciğim bu soruyu sen çözüyorsun. Önce
sen dediğimde lütfen bu tarz sorularda
önce sen yapacaksın. Tamam mı? Gerçekten
bu işi öğrenmek istiyor musun benimle
birlikte? Lütfen aç kitabında. Bu 3ün
soruyu benden önce çözmeye çalış. Ben
beklerim biraz. Ya da durdurs videoyu.
Ben devam edeyim sonrasında. Tamam
mıyız?
Üzerine takılan doğru yanlış bulman
önemli değil. Yanlış da bulsan, doğru da
olsan ne seni kötüleyeceğim ne de
öveceğim. Bir şeyler için uğraştığım
için seni tebrik edeceğim. Tek derdim
benim bu. Matematik adına uğraşmaya
başladıkça o işten zevk alırsın. Zevk
aldıkça zaten ileride hepsini doğru
yapacaksın. Şimdi değil. Zaman geldikçe
doğru yapmaya başlayacaksın. Adım adım.
Çok acele etmeyeceksin. Üzerine takılan
sensör yardımıyla ölçüm yapabilen bir su
borusundan bir dakikada geçen su miktarı
mililetre türünden aşağıdaki görselde
verilmiştir. Bir kere matematik yapmak
istiyorsan Türkçe okuduğunu
anlayacaksın. Ne burada? 1 dakikada
geçen su miktarı mililitre türünden
verilmiş. Bak yazıyorum. 1 dakikada
geçen su miktarı 216. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 neymiş? Militre ml
şeklinde yazılıyor. Militre cinsinden
verilmiş. Ne dediyse aynen yazdım. Buna
göre bu su borusundan saniyede geçen su
miktarının litre türünden bilimsel
gösterimini bulur musunuz? Bak soru
mililitre cinsinden vermiş. Ne cinsinden
istiyor benden? Litre türünden. Bir kere
benim öncelikle bana verilen ifadeyi
litre türünden yazmam lazım. 1 litre
neye eşit? 100 ml eşit. 100 mlreye eşit
olduğuna göre benim ilk yapacağım şey
şuradaki mililitreyi pardon 1000'e eşit
1000 mlreye eşit. 1000'e bölmem
gerekmiyor mu? Bir dakikada geçen suyu
litre cinsinden bulacağım. 1000'e
bölersem 1 2 3 0 1 2 3 0. Ben artık şunu
buldum bak. Hocam 1 dakikada geçen su
miktarı 216. 1 2 3 4 5 0 1 2 3 4 5 0
Yani şunları da şöyle düzenlersem şöyle
21.600.000
L midir artık nereden geçiyorsa bu doğru
mudur? Bu kaç dakikada? 60 dakikada. Sen
ne zaman geçen suyu istiyorsun?
Saniyede. E bir dakika buraya bir bilgi
daha yazalım. Hocam 1 dakika dediğin şey
kaç saniyeye eşit? 60 saniyeye eşit.
Aslında buradaki ifade kaç saniyede
geçen su miktarını veriyor bana? 60
saniyede. Sen neyi istiyorsun? 1
saniyede geçen su miktarını istiyorsun.
O halde sana verilen 216 sonundaki 1 2 3
4 5 tane verilen sıfırlı ifadeyi kaça
bölmen gerekiyor? 60'a bölmen gerekiyor.
Bu 60 saniyede geçen. Bir saniyede
geçeni bulmak için 60'a bölüyorsun.
0ırları yedik mi? Yine yedik. 216'yı
aldım. Kenarda 6'ya böleceğim bak. Tamam
mı? 3 kere 6'dan ne geldi? 18. Şuradan
çıkarttım. 2 3 36 6 x 6 ne yaptı? 36
yaptı. Çıkarttım. Aa direkt 36 geldi
zaten. Şunla şu sadeleşti. Şurada 36
kaldı. 36 sonunda da 1 2 3 4 tane de 0 1
2 3 4 tane 0. Şimdi önce diyor ki soru
bunu bilimsel gösterimle göstermiz.
Hocam buradaki ifade litre cinsinden bu
arada bu ifade 36 x 1 2 3 4 tane 0 yapar
mı? Yapar. 10 üzeri 4 yaptı. Şimdi tek
derdim hocam. Bilimsel gösterim bu
değildir. 3 küsürlü olmalı. Yani 1 ile
10 arasında olmalı. Oradaki değer 1'e
eşit olabilirdi. Virgülü buraya mı
atacağım? Buraya atacağım. Virgül
nereden geldi? Sağ tarafta görünmeyen
virgülümüz vardı. Sola doğru gelmiş
oldum. Sayıyı küçültmeye çalışıyorum.
Değil mi? 3,6 yapıyorsam bunu
küçültürsem bunu büyüteceksin. Demek ki
bunun üstüne 1 ekleyeceksin. Değil mi?
Virgül sola gidiyorsa onun kuvveti 1
artar. 3,6 x 10 üzeri 5 Lredir
cevabımız. Çok da güzel bir cevap. Çok
da güzel bir soru. Ben sınav ayarında
bir soru olduğunu düşünüyorum. Hatta
biraz da zorladı seni eminim. Ama güzel
öğreniyoruz.
Aşağıda üç farklı madenin ağırlık
merkezlerinin doğrusal olarak metre
cinsinden uzunlukları verilmiş. Buna
göre M ile C arasındaki ağırlık
merkezleri arasındaki uzaklık yine metre
cinsinden ama bu sefer bilimsel
gösterimle bulunsun diyor. Arkadaş
nereyi istiyor senden? B ile C
arasındaki ağırlık merkezleri arasındaki
uzaklık. Burayı istiyor. Doğru mudur? E
ne yaparsın mantıken? Hocam bizim
elimizde buranın tamamının Allah
üstünden geçmiş gibi olurum o zaman.
Buranın tamamı var. Şu parçayı
çıkartırsam eğer x kalır mı bana? Evet x
kalır. O halde x'in cevabını bulabilmem
için 70,2 x 10 üzeri 9'dan neyi çıkarmam
lazım? 100,2 x 10 üssü 8'i çıkarmam
lazım. Bir dakika dedim. Durdum önce
bir. Hocam üslü sayılarda toplama
çıkarma yapabilmem için üslerin
birbirine eşit olması lazım. O zaman
büyük olanı küçük olana eşitleyelim.
Şimdi 10 üzeri 9 bu. 10 üzeri 9'un
içerisinde aslında kaç tane onluk var?
Ulan hepsini yazmasam iyiydi ha. 9 tane
onluk var. Ama tabii çarpmayı, bölmeyi
anlatmadığımız için biraz bekletiyorum.
Burada 9 tane onluk var. Bunun bir
tanesini kenara ayırdığında burada ne
kalır? 10 üzeri 8 kalır. O zaman mevzu
şu. 70,2
x 10 x 10,8 10 üzeri 8. Niye? Bir tane
onluğunu kenara kayırdım. -1,2 x 10
üzeri 8. Şu sayıyla şu sayıyı çarpalım
mı? Bir sayıyı 10'la çarpmak demek. Eğer
virgüllü bir sayıysa o virgülü sağa
doğru kaydırmak demektir. 702 x 10 üssü
8 - 100,2 x 10 üsü 8. Şimdi üslü
sayılarda çıkarma işlemi yapıyorum.
Tabanlar üstler aynı mı? Aynı. 10 üssü
8'i yazalım mı? Yazalım. Yazamadım tam.
10 üssü 8'i yazdım. Buradaki ifade kaç?
702 hocam. Buradaki ifade kaç? 100,2.
Hocam ne yapıyorum? Birbirinden
çıkartıyorum. Şimdi çıkartırken burada 0
var. Kabul ettim. Bu ifadeyi çıkarttım.
Şurada ne kaldı? 8 kaldı. Şurada 1
kaldı. Şu 1'i aşağı indim. Şurada 0.
Şurada 6. Virgül aynen olduğu yere
devam. 601,8
x 10 üzeri 8 soru. Bilimsel gösterim
diyor. Dedim ya bak bu sorunun en kritik
noktası bilimsel gösterim. Abi virgül
nerede? Burada olmaz. 6'nın oraya kadar
geleceğim. Kaç tane kaydırdım? 2 tane.
Virgülü 2 tane kaydırmak demek
şu şekilde bir sayı elde ettik. Bunun
üstünü ya hocam arttırıyor muyduk?
Azaltıyor muyduk? Abi virgül sola doğru
giderse burası azalır mı? O zaman bunun
ne yapması lazım? Sayının değişmemesi
için artması lazım. 2 tane mi kaydırdık?
O zaman buraya ne yazdım artık? 10 üssü
10 yazdım. Artık bu ifadenin de bilimsel
gösterimi 6,018 x 10 üsü 10'dur dedim.
Mük bir soruyla daha noktayı koydum.
Artık ne yapıyorsun? Şurayı güzel bir
tekrar ediyorsun. Bu arada biz ne yapmış
olduk? Şu kısmı beraber bitirmiş olduk.
Ardından şuradaki güzel soruları bir
tekrar ediyorsun. Hakkını vererek
çözdük. Vallahi inşallah sen de kitabına
yine bunların hakkını vererek
çözüyorsundur güzel arkadaşım. Bir şey
daha söyleyeceğim. Bir sonraki derste
çarpmayı, bölmeyi, üslü sayılarda artık
envai çeşit soru tarzlarına beraber
bakacağız. Sonrasında ne yapıyorsun?
Necda hocamızla birlikte burada kare
kodu var. Oynatma listesine açılıyor. O
buradaki bütün soruların çözümlerini
yaptı kanalında. Oradaki çözümleri de
izliyorsun. Buradaki bütün ödevleri bir
sonra gidersin sonunda yapıyorsun.
Ödevleri yapmazsan, ödevlerle, sorularla
baş başa kalmazsan bu iş olmaz. Onu
baştan söyleyeyim. Gerçekten ödev
soruları bizim için kıymetli. Ödev
sorularını çözmende fayda var. Öğrenmek
de istiyorsun. Matematiği öğrenmek
istiyorsan tek kanaat, tek olay bu.
Öğrenerek ilerlediğinde 4 yıl sonra
geriye dönmek zorunda kalmayacaksın. Bu
kızlar daha seninle neler neler
yapacağız sen hiç merak etme. Dediğim
gibi matematik işi rehber matematikte
Emin. Sen yeter ki diğer dersleri
halletsin. O zaman bir sonraki derste
görüşeceğiz. Kendine iyi bak. Hoş kal.
Hoşça kal.
[Müzik]
He.
Yeah.